me and my sister we have a past we  almost died at the hands of a witch that  past made us stronger we've gotten to  tasted blood witch blood  and we haven't stopped since  my name is Gretel and this is my brother  Hansel I'm not going to have you telling  me what to do how do you best kill a  witch cutting off her head tends to work  hate that one the last two weeks we have  five children taken from us which does  not come out in the open like that I  don't think we're hunting watches  there's something else going on here  we have to find those kids shoot  anything that moves see you got my  invitation I have my sister  [Music]  last No  what is sunshine  you got it Academy